[Music]
[Music]
well hello it's Friday the 13th
I'm here with John bleep sucky I might
my hearty stop playing dead space
because as of tomorrow it's 9 years old
today so October 14th right ok and it
would make more sense would be the 13th
I think it's the 13th yeah we're gonna
be playing right from the beginning yep
yeah
[Music]
sweet yeah we've got the YouTube twitch
chats open anybody wants to join in be
talking about dead space we also want to
talk about yeah ask any questions
comments but it's got a cool history the
game itself it's one of the more
intriguing EA published titles I'd say
the fact that they took a chance on this
back in 2007 when they first announced
it 2006 I think when they first start
developing it but there's gonna be
System Shock 3 with like Glen Schofield
who would go on to do like sledgehammer
game Infinity Ward stuff before he left
Infinity Ward but when resident 4 came
out at 2005 it would have been they saw
that and we're like okay we should
switch gears instead of doing System
Shock 3 which is also now in development
and with Warren Spector they said okay
let's let's make this horror game
survival horror third-person action
after a resonable for kind of set the
precedent for that every the bar for
that I would say yeah and as far as like
games are like our I hated call it a
resonable clones I don't like ice giving
it enough credit but it hasn't evil
inspired this is one of the my personal
favorites oh yeah for sure
it's I mean obviously the series is
known for being a yeah I think they
became visceral for Dead Space 3 -
interesting choice was not expecting
dead space gotta keep you on your toes
yeah we got the all the reviews are out
for the evil within - today
maybe yesterday but Alessandra like that
he gave me an 8 out of 10 I played about
a couple hours of it on Xbox I'm liking
it so far I'm gonna finish it up tonight
this weekend yeah I'm I will over
halfway through that game up the volume
for people I'm sorry about everything
what's happening
strange how many times you watch that
thing guess you really miss her don't
worry witness there you'll be able to
look her up here sinking our a bit now
while this trouble yeah there's Glenn
Schofield some life in anymore 37 is
gold wine according to prospectors
reports cobalt thing is like oz may want
the core team know that work not based
on where they work at issues this roller
is this role now is doing the yeah
whatever 1313 has become biggest would
be then again sorry corporal take us in
closer and hailed them and stay clear
that debris field it's it's super alien
butt oh that's all you waste anymore
this is responding to your distress I
get a lot of I'm in DC more now what's
that really bad movie that's or like
even like it was to signal lost in space
you see that Gary Oldman and then Liam
hurt yes yes isn't matt LeBlanc in that
people are we friends
I coulda sworn he was me too maybe I
could be wrong it's a busted array like
we thought
sounds like they're having problems with
their encoder we were talking about
gravity tethers engaged automatic
docking procedures ago
we're gonna hit the hole hit the flash
shoot yeah Eric's taking the day off
today because me and gentlemen both love
this game so we decide the pollen tier
de Larroque relax
just a little better from the booster
and we've lost comms and autopilot it'll
take some time to write that's got some
extra hands some flag dick to help out
it's the typical like every man just
engineer not soldier oh yeah it's still
Isaac you know I was thinking if
everyone's Rick with the shadows like
yeah you ever do the plan better fight
through that game that gun is my
favorite like video you've ever jumped
yeah it's not there with a gravity gun
even know what else pistol from Halo one
so that's how long were playing for now
we're hour and a half fish yeah go until
Michael little depending on where we're
at in the game it is save point at
that's tram station interesting tidbit
we're here in San Francisco if those who
don't know the sounds of the monorail in
this game were recorded in that Park
stations in oh they're really yeah so I
mean you know you don't write by really
gently but you have before vacuuming
yeah it's funny when I first came here I
[Music]
would say this was this is my favorite
thing to come out of the last generation
of consoles I mean there are other
things like I would say like portal 2 is
also there's a fair amount of games yeah
new I feels like franchises specific to
that generation I'd say this Bioshock
was also good he obviously gets more
action II with 2 and 3 I really like
those games not as much as I like this
I like them for their own reasons like
three it was crazy balls to the wall
action but I like the crafting in that
the weapon I'm mixed on three I'm like
half and a half on that game I like a
lot of the space the the first third act
where it's in space is pretty good yeah
and I like the idea of like flipping the
horror on its head where it's like it's
not instead of it being dark it's just
like oh it's snow and you can't see
anything I think as much as they could
have yeah I also didn't like John Carver
that much if that's his if memory serves
because he would like pop in and out of
cuts in randomly in a way at the second
so Nagi apparently apologies I'm putting
them on YouTube yeah this is great from
the beginning of the game and this is on
pc yeah it's it is weird to me everybody
has already been saying it and they when
we announced this morning they're been
they were tweeting at me and GameSpot
accounts saying why has he a not
released the ps4 Xbox one trilogy it's
backwards compatible compatible an Xbox
one correct I believe yes but it's not
up up res or anything it's not it's not
HD or you know new generation one thing
I find whatever I play I don't think
this one I said whenever I play to on PC
it just automatically gives you a
pre-order bonus stuff oh really
the problem is that it keeps me wall on
your inventory so where you start that
game out after you do like oh really get
like all look like the level 5 seats
right away and it completely like that
ruins the
just like any sense of progression in
that game that just seems
counterintuitive for what these names
are right so I Michael Hernandes who's
asking us where we
let me put the dead space games in our
horror games list like as a franchise
I'd say it might be second to Resident
Evil third maybe after resonable Silent
Hill in terms of this game specifically
I mean I me and you were both big fans
of remake that's one of my fav
remakes probably number one that's one
of my favorite games ever yes like the
drawers mask and so yeah I'd say this
game is probably three or four maybe
after like resi will remake and I don't
even know like resi before even though
that's not really that helped II was
somewhere in there I'd played Salman
forever though I hadn't played any of
those games in a long time I tried I
never played something one so a couple
years ago I tried to play it and I end
up getting stuck I mean a friend were
playing yeah kind of given up I would
like to maybe go back sometime let me
see if I can finish it bud yeah totally
the Silent Hill games hold up but like
in terms of being games out there kind
of yeah a little rough but the
atmosphere is still like almost
unmatched I love those games like Silent
Hill itself
yeah the someone who just Anthony Lozano
and the YouTube said but the game came
out on the 14th we were talked about
that the beginning jean-luc said if you
just look it up on Google it'll show up
as October 14th 2008 and you look up in
Wikipedia like that yeah the dead space
wiki it since the 13th so it's yeah I'm
not sure yeah I think though they would
have done the 13th right it makes sense
yeah I mean unless that was like unless
the 14th was a Tuesday the 13th was in
Monday right but regardless we're not
gonna be in well most of us won't be in
the office tomorrow which is a Saturday
and it's October 13th and any excuse to
play this game pretty much
you and I John Luke both watch mark
Browns game makers toolkit at his lot he
was saying like the way that this game
introduces like you have to cut off
their limbs kind of goes against the
whole headshot trope it's really cool I
mean like it's literally written in
blood it's nothing subtle but it's still
know they introduced it to you in a way
that yeah it doesn't like come up in a
menu box saying it does it it actually
does okay but the first time was on the
wall right yeah yeah the game like is a
little hand I'd say that's a complaint
about the game that I didn't think about
until he brought it up in a video where
he this games maybe a little hand hold
II yeah especially I mean it has the
literal telling you where to go I wonder
if that was like I wonder if this game
if something like this was made today
well things like this happen made and
they're more willing to let players
figure it out but for a while there I
feel like everything was kind of holding
our hands a lot of Indian Tendo things
for doing that yeah Nintendo has been
easing off that a lot this year which
has been nice so like I think about like
the fable to breadcrumb trail yeah that
was like the start of this very lame
yeah but speaking of the gravity gun in
half-life 2
that was great like the way they showed
you how you could shoot saw blades
because it was in a zombie and you could
miss it or it was in one of the in
Ravenholm is in the zombie but you could
miss it but if you saw that you could
say logically oh I can reach let me take
this and then shoot it right at them
it's like one hit kill yeah yeah yeah my
friend is a really great series they
balance like they're in action
that's definitely recommend those as you
say he has a favorite is usually pretty
not not objective but he's takes a step
back yeah cuz I think one's got the
clearest identity yeah vision like pure
eating you to it I do love to like I
love to you could see how to started to
introduce threes action stuff in again I
like three for its own reasons I do
think one is still the best
yeah but I think two balances things too
much I mean it's very much like the
aliens to the alien for me you know like
sure yeah exactly
there's people who love the purity of
the horror of the first alien or aliens
my players I think dead space do you
have some really good action set-pieces
and [ __ ] yeah as well just last week I
believe Alessandra who just reviewed or
evil than to he did are evil within to
review and that's John Luke cut his
video review for him and that's up on
YouTube GameSpot and I don't read that
gave it eight out of ten really good
better than the first one from walk by
all accomplice
Alessandra also did a revisiting alien
isolation feature last week I believe
yeah pretty good and I still I've been
telling people this on the lobby or live
show and like dead air podcast and a lot
of things I still have not touched alien
isolation I've well oh really
and I love alien I don't know why it's
become that thing that like I'm always
saying I really need to play and then it
becomes such a task I've heard things
about it that turn me off like the
checkpoint system how long it is but I
still need to play it try I mean my big
issue at that game
feels it goes on a couple hours too long
yeah
it just like casing wise but up until
that point I thought it was real I don't
know patrollin or if they're serious if
they are king frederick ii the Great of
Prussia said three was the best
installment I've seen a couple people
saying three I so at the time I was
writing for this like grassroots indie
site called gaming Nexus and I reviewed
that that was like my first big review
and then I did like the Last of Us cuz
des phase 3 was 2013 correct so that
would've been yeah that would have been
before right before the Last of Us I
think because the Last of Us was the
summer after dead space 3 I'll
double-check this but I'm fairly
positive that's base 3 of the spring and
I loved it and I hadn't played the first
two in a while so I wasn't really I
wasn't faulting it for not being like
these two as an action game I liked it a
lot like you said there were definitely
problems with it's more like definitely
with its horror but the crafting aspects
and the the actual combat I loved but
mmm
yeah going back after with me I think
one is still definitely the best
although two again is very impressive
and how it balances those two poles I
three was also kind of weirdly relevant
one of the first games to like this
example like shoehorning and
microtransactions knew a game that
didn't originally have it like in parts
yeah that's right graphing stuff and
that's kind of still relevant things
like a you know shadow of a war and loot
boxes and all that stuff for as a seven
apparently battlefront two hatched a lot
of that after the beta yeah they've
apparently done a just good but yeah
yeah I haven't read it yet but yeah he's
like yep we're gonna address it and
because the
we've listened to feedback which is good
that they're doing that skeptical you
can't wonder at our mercy yeah that's
what Rob was saying
I imagine maybe like Rob is saying maybe
it's just it's good press for them to
change it but I mean we'll see it comes
out November like 15 mid November
sometime not too far away I mean it's a
month away I guess it is kind of far
away considering there's how many more
games between now five next week is
crazy for these could be getting two
games in here two weeks from now is when
everybody be playing Mario Assassin's
Creed Wolfenstein all three of which are
I'm really excited for yeah varying
degrees this week right now is like a
calm before the storm and it's enjoyable
as hell like I'm not complaining but
it's still gonna be crazy
even then I
I was so that - or - yeah so I was kind
of thing and it hasn't been as common so
I want it to before I'm like sitting
you're playing evil then but yeah I'm
actually very happy with advertisers I
did figure out gloss over it I liked the
first one for what it was I keep telling
you and people in the office there's 15
chapters I love ten of them hate the
last five really hate the last five
there's a turret sequence the boss with
that giant eyeballs bad but - I'm only
two hours into it you are you done with
it sänger I was very pleasantly
surprised and talking to him I said hey
does the game ever do what does it ever
kind of like jump the shark because
Charlie brought up an interesting point
on the lobby that's just sort of
something have to accept this is like
every horror movies - yeah yeah before
movies more games always just sort of
like jump the shark a little bit the
last third and he said like no the game
does that it doesn't kind of become more
action at the end like it has elements
admirable I mean like that's like yeah
like that's good you want that terms of
movies I mean what's it the cabin in the
woods I won't I mean it's been out for a
while I won't spoil it in case people
having son you should watch that if you
even if you don't love horror you should
watch cabin the woods but like they make
fun of that whole third act craziness in
a really cool way
almost parodying it but uh it always
reminds me yeah like most movies will do
that toward the end and that's I'm eager
to see the end of evil within two if it
kind of subverts that yeah well the very
least yet just doesn't
I remember this game maybe being a touch
too long if I have
oh yeah it didn't bother me the first
time playing through but in subsequent
playthroughs ever and be like okay yeah
gotta go back to this part and do that
again remember to head to is one where
you escape on the dropship in the final
sequence right it was kind of like a
halo the classic action game ending
where it's like a chase escape scene I
think that was - that space - because
this one there's a massive boss it's a
massive bone what's her name
yeah choose more like running through
this gauntlet and of course like stews
all about Isaac looking into insanity
yeah three like kind of is already gone
well they play with that idea but yeah
not as much was that your game article
where they talk about the original plan
for like the dementia and how carpet was
originally actually gonna be like a
shadow version of Isaac well okay didn't
he end up kind of being like the Tyler
Durden wasn't it like a Tyler Durden
twist that was yeah he's basically
keeping exist and they're gonna like
mess with the idea of like players
seeing things that weren't there which
they do a tiny bit in Dead Space 3 like
there are co-op specific levels that you
could only do it for playing co-op yeah
and those will have those moments in
there but they're very what was the DLC
ecology 3 is the DLC wasn't that the
case rival yes and wasn't that the case
that Carver like you see Carver again
but he was he's there but he's dead the
whole time
that DLC the DLC completely changed the
ending of the trilogy affected my ducks
it does it basically and it three
endzone kind of like a hopeful mode
hopeful like ah you know yeah I'll get
better then the ending of that basically
is like no actually everyone dies yeah
and the kind of sucks not like a good
way it's like almost a director's cut I
don't know it's yeah it's it's very
weird I have the feed lore the back
story is that space actually gets all
pretty cool it's cool but like most war
things I think they they focus on it too
much like it one it's really they keep
it vague in a way where it's like oh
this is cool and interesting but then
when they have to like explain it a
little more exposition later on and
exactly I do like the cultist stuff for
them Altman yeah and then it is raised
yeah what's the unit Allah okay she'll
college and that yes okay so I always
confuse that with Unitarian which is a
real world religion unit ology is like
the whole they find the markers and
Elise
the via Church unit ology champion -
that's really cool like the Gothic
cathedral it's that and then the nursery
that I always think I'm gonna think of -
God yeah I know I remember the backstory
stuff being cool like the whole Altman
thing like there's actually like a book
that like explains that you know videos
yeah books but basically like the
protagonist is Altman and you find out
that like he actually like knew the
markers were like that business oh yeah
he kind of ended becoming this like
martyr that these other people basically
were like we're gonna use him to form
this like religious good Jesus figure
yeah that sounds cool
it's cool cool fiction that the games at
least the first game I think handles in
a good enough way words
yeah and that's always tough I mean you
look at a ton of video game series you
look at the movie so I get alien and
aliens it's tough to the first
installment is inherently gonna have a
lot of mystery like the first haloa is
still my favorite because you go to halo
you don't really know what's going on
you haven't seen the flood yet and then
to of course you go back to earth and
you know a lot more there's less mystery
it's more about the fight and sure and
it's tough but I mean like you alien and
aliens do the same thing but that's just
I guess there are also different
directors in very different movies but
it's kind of a tough thing to ignore I
think some of the I think that space 2
is good about talking about the lore but
not too much I think it's not that you
dislike the expedition a little more
than I did but 3 definitely gets way to
explaining I would say I also don't
remember - as much as I remember 3 I
remember I love to though
you still feel good playing it now yeah
feels pretty good I love it's not as
precise like I remember two and three
like the it's very precise controls a
little floaty you mean intentionally and
then like the way see like the way the
laser is present in before laser yeah
which they got rid of in like three it's
just great apply freeze it's the default
a dot and then you could hand turn and a
lot of guns in three are more like
conventional just single-shot
semi-automatic not beam energy right
it's all yeah there's some backtracking
in this game but it's it's it's
structured like resin before where you
come up to and resting before it's the
merchant and there would be a typewriter
in a save fish room but then this is
like the translations are kind of the
main save points with the lockers and
seat upgrade stations and we were
actually talking right before this but
you know looking at Isaac's suit and
that Ishimura itself when you first see
at the beginning and a lot of the not
just the Necromorph design but the
actual mechanical industrial design in
this game and throughout the series is
all modeled after animal carcasses like
ribs and if you it's actually one of the
few art books that I mean not that art
books are bad but like they're kind of
overdone but like I agree dead space the
art the story behind the art book that
you can get with like limited editions
you could buy it by itself now but it's
really cool it shows all the inspiration
behind like how McCobb they want it to
go and they're like we essentially
looked at pig carcasses and skeletons to
make it anymore and stuff super visceral
I would say yeah but it's it's a really
interesting read if you get the chance
to check it out I love our books but I
am very picky about them because I do
think they're overdone and I'm like Alan
you know I put for every game but dead
space was one of the first ones I I
picked up because I wanted that yeah
okay I mean there's like Hyrule historia
which is good which is more than an art
book that's a good one
keep everybody in the chat seems to be
saying like we want a dead space for cuz
he a has mentioned I don't do it man cuz
they mentioned it's not completely out
of the question but if they did it would
need to be like a I would rather I think
fictionally they've kind of mind this
this fiction to death right I would
rather it more spiritual successor to
that and I have to imagine like
obviously all their Star Wars efforts
kind of put everything else on the back
burner aside from like battlefield
sports games etc right but I think it's
more likely that they do with dead space
for or reboot instead of a new IP I
would say that is true that is true but
I know as though if you want to call it
dead space but it's like a completely
different setting like you know universe
I'd be I'd be into packs I just
I think this universe is it was not
really much else to go with it yeah
go burn that thing over there I just
love games especially horror games and
confined settings like resonable is all
the mansion this is all issue more uh
it's I mean it's like the Nostromo and a
lien but yeah I like singular setting
for your backtracking most Metroid games
this game does they're a little Metroid
flavor in here yeah fully but a little
bit yeah you're not really getting new
abilities that often I mean you're
getting stasis and telekinesis but you
have those right from the beginning
right already do you have you don't have
telekinesis and those too because I'm I
mean like if you are doing the all
plasma cutter run those do become pretty
important yes they're pretty important
regardless but right I think evil within
two will scratch some of that edge
hopefully yeah it already kind of is
deaf people into is so Last of Us though
like we were talking about are the parts
I've seen it's like suburban stealth
upgrades and everything it just feels
very much like I mean the pacing of the
last of us yeah the first game
functionally was very last most yeah
well let's give also being real Marlon
the deaths yeah there's the one where
your head gets oh Jesus haha yes I love
that his head's gone but uh it doesn't
matter who's one we're like your head
gets knocked off and then this like
other head like skull like crawls yeah
and to you and like replaces her head
and then you start like walking around
for like a couple seconds before he came
over it's so long I mean like now I'm
thinking at the Last of Us there's the
one where the bloater I think they're
called the in the gymnasium if he grabs
Joel's jaw just surprise his face open
put any benny-boy 5:35 and you twist I
was saying there's a post on there's a
reddit post on dead space a while ago
with a great pitch for DES base for
that's totally separate from Isaac's
story I did not see that I might want to
check that oh yeah for anybody who's
kind of itching for more on that I mean
but it's like completely devoid of Isaac
that would be okay too this goes without
saying to but between how the menus are
all in world and his health and ammo
world yeah this is definitely by default
not just like it's not a no HUD mode
it's just how the game was this is how
the game works and I think like the
reason I like no HUD modes it's
something I always try with to do with
the game is because I like the idea I
always feel like hugs just it's not
about challenging us areas about that I
just kind of distract you know removal
from it because you're looking on the
mini-map you're looking at how this
diegetic and non-diegetic can actually
do that
[Music]
Wayne Pinkston on YouTube we're playing
on PC but he's using the Xbox one
controller that's what you're you saw
the interface and we're wondering
I'm given this way
you have a favorite level in this game I
don't know everything in this game kind
of blends together I mean I maybe I just
haven't played it in a while but I mean
like - has those like you said the
nursery and the church but I'm trying to
think of one my favorite from two is
actually when you come back to the floor
that's a really good luck oh right and
that isn't the ship don't you go into
the docking bay isn't that how you're
trying to yeah you visit like multiple
areas from this it's really it's a cool
school um man I don't I'm trying to
think of specific levels in this I mean
there are moments the the ones that
stand out for me is I remember the first
time you come across the regenerator I
think yeah really good that's a level I
like a lot and then I really liked the
it's the bridge one where you first come
across that tanky dude what's the what's
the machine that you're trying to
reactivate and you're using telekinesis
to like insert those nodes but the whole
time you're doing it it's it's timed but
you also are fighting off guys it's like
in though I think it's like in the
mechanical Bay or something and that
docking bay or something I don't know I
always remember that being terrifying
because you have this objective of apart
from just surviving that you're trying
to focus on as well yeah and I know what
you're talking about
yeah then the game sells fast one it
when they just sort of like taking its
elements and then kind of mixing them up
and yeah yeah so it's not just you're
dealing with enemies but then you're
also trying to like yeah solve like a
puzzle or it before another task I do
like when you start getting into the
what's his girlfriend's name that he
came here for Nicole oh yeah when you
start running my hand yeah I mean like
when you kind of it starts it starts
revealing that Isaac's not here just out
of duty for his job right there's like a
personal aspect to it which doesn't
always have to happen but I think they
introduced it well and he's obviously
he's a silent protagonist but mmm it
helps that uh there is some sort of
motivation outside of I'm just an
engineer here to fix the like why I like
Ellen Ripley she develops these personal
motivations
what's the what's the other weapon
called not the only other weapon but the
line gun line cutter line cutter it was
this a good one yeah really powerful
yeah
essentially the assault rifle to the
plasma cutter pistol yeah anyway there
may be nice obviously they have for
people who don't know it's how many for
reticles that come out it's like it
looks like a crossbow but she has
literal lines of plasma energy
what I definitely picked the medium but
I
just cruising through it kind of
cruising through it maybe I so much King
Frederick was asking us if they have
mods for Dead Space 3 on pc never tried
well let me check it's only available on
Origin I don't know how Steam Workshop
wouldn't really wouldn't be right
computer I don't know what I would I
mean because of all the options but I
mean in its slight defense it is still a
recent mishap but those would still be
gone but yeah now yeah you think they
would find some other way besides handle
to illustrate like religious cult like
right they do they get they a lot on the
walls the blood and the this simple
scrolled on the walls is enough I don't
necessarily need the you have to go the
four-mile with the candles yeah
yet people joining and Glenna Tron on
YouTube is saying dead space anniversary
is tomorrow we had spoken a couple times
wit media says October 13th google says
October 14th but regardless it's Friday
the 13th one play a horror game and this
game is tomorrow anniversary is on a
Saturday if it is the 14th it's not a
Saturday
he's getting that suit I know there's a
new map
in Friday the 13th the game the
asymmetrical multiplayer a new map way
there's a new Jason I think it's based
on both of the fourth one the final
chapter games fun very very janky but
yeah when it works it can be pretty cool
it's just enough it's worth like for me
a Lee's like the time sing to get to
those good moments can be a little tough
yeah especially when it's like I have so
many other things I could be playing yep
yeah I even went into good timing came
out today tango gameworks and Shinji
Mikami a good games Akita producer of
Resident Evil if you're named in that
game I would recommend getting it just
cuz I would like to see that game do
well I feel like that games not gonna
sell very no I don't think so
I'm coming out right after I mean shadow
war I think shadow war will do fine and
that is just kind of unfortunate next
week or two weeks from now is four games
never so well what about Wolfenstein
will do on the same day as this asin's
creed and Mario both of those will kick
ass especially Mar well I don't know
it's hard to underestimate Assassin's
Creed especially the first one in two
years and it looks like from our
standpoint it looks good - at least it's
weird like Mario Mario is a good some
beast right like it's separate you know
switch only kind of hard to say but then
something like no nodes yeah like we
just so ubiquitous I'm on everything
especially come to think of it this is
the first Assassin's Creed main like
main entry console entry since the movie
right I wonder how many key that'll
bring in
oh do you think there's like people who
like I don't know sorry they didn't
already an yeah so like I I wonder how
many people saw the movie and don't even
have a console and haven't seen a
Centauri before there can't be that many
like you said it's a pervasive franchise
yeah I feel it goes already very
well-known at that point sure that's
kill it
Wolfenstein will do a bit as well
oh yeah it's gonna do well based off of
the word of mouth and it's like critical
reception like a lot of people like that
yeah last game oh I and I think it's
just it just looks rad every time I see
a trailer I'm saying this game looks
awesome
it just doesn't give a [ __ ] like yeah
you go to your [ __ ] riding those
Panzer Huns the machines you're you're
fighting a Nazi a Nazi occupied in
America go to New Orleans with
alligators it's right it's going all the
way that game mix is like very pulpy
like we got to go to area 51 and stop
the Nazis mixed with like this
their their eyes that's what they do
right they remove their eyes she's got
her eyes removed
no no what they do is they they stab a
hole in their brain because that's how
the neck like okay something like
preparing their like heads to be turned
yeah
she's blind
listen the ragdoll
can you move around yes or I mean just
by watching or that she Scott oh there's
the way you go like blonde respectful of
the dead I mean in your defense you
probably don't want to leave dead bodies
lying around when Necromorph sir
yeah right you got a thing
yeah Matt Mars that Marcille I said dude
you go ape on Nazis in a wheelchair
can't beat that
yeah that's one of the second do you
played right yes it's like the opening
of the game we don't have that gaming
off yet we're fortunate enough that
Bethesda despite their in the last year
or so their review policy of not really
sending out copies until like the night
before they sent evil within to about a
week in advance hopefully that happens
with Wolfenstein to you know I think
Kali will be reviewing it she's been
playing the new orders to refresh we're
all talking what the order of do this
gameplay on that day not to mention
stranger things season to come same day
right I was Wolfenstein Mario storage so
dense you almost want it's more time
with that game yeah Wolfenstein you know
it'll be like a good 15 18 hour capture
probably Mario Mario games are never
there long but they're not like a long
long like I feel like you could play
like a most 3d Mario games and like what
like 20 25 hours yeah this one seems
like it'll be longer I think this one's
like 30th because of how have you seen
the gameplay where they showed scrolling
through those power moons or whatever
you're collecting how many that's I've
been trying to avoid okay there's only a
lot like even for a Mario game the
that's good don't even say like I it's
also worth noting obviously the Odyssey
will be easier to play on the switch I
can play that whenever kind of maybe
between everything else I finally if I
get like half the power point and just
want to go back to it between Assassin's
Creed sessions that's a possibility but
Wolfenstein I think will be best played
like straight through in a couple days
or so mmm oh yeah I I when I play new
order I like didn't want to stop playing
it so I feel yeah that's probably gonna
be the way I play
new Colossus because then the the week
after is um call it Duty World War two
and then I think it's battled weeks
after that it's like the eleventh or
something that's it
after battlefront I think that's the end
as you know blade chronicles that this
that's um no that's December right ibly
chronicles - am I saying that right yeah
i chronicles not excite for that I've
never played a Xenoblade watched I
touched the original one on Wii U a
little bit but might be consensus which
brother is like a massive fan of those
game yeah played a you know gear on like
ps1 so I feel like I
he's just been recommending yeah guy
should finally try one speaking of like
contiguous environments on a space
station pray came out early this year
some horror aspects to it yeah I love
right it's one of my top five for sure I
actually put it in my you know that uh
that Twitter thing oh you're like
gameshow potential significant others to
like illustrate you as a person so I put
pray on that yeah because for me I was
like oh I would put an immersive sim
yeah and my thoughts would go to System
Shock 2 would be though would be the one
that I personally would play but you
don't want to force someone to play that
and coin 70 exactly I'm like I think
pray is like the closest analogy to like
here's yeah you understand what I'm
getting at and it's also like wave
easier to play or they're you know what
did I put on that
majora's mask Zombies Ate My Neighbors
red alert to maybe
timesplitters 2 and halo 1 nice prey
through sauna for Resident Evil remake
mass spec to set it I don't think so
gray mass spec to whatever that
important man dead space's
really play the scanner I mean I think
the pacing of this game is so great it's
hard to put down even though it's I mean
would you say this is like resonable for
length like it's 15 hours or so yeah I
mean resin will for at first playthrough
no I'm sure you and I could be resin
before most but still four and five
games I like to it kind of just speed
through yeah Jean Constantine Jordan on
YouTube apologies my apologies by
butchering that said Team Fortress 2 I'm
just reading a story on Waypoint
yesterday about how the ps3 Team
Fortress 2 community is still thriving
like they're just keeping it alive on
ps3 and with an orange box
I was watching a what you know the
youtuber crow but that he does like
those YouTube videos
[Applause]
if you don't mess back to Andromeda yeah
like he's six years and how many
millions of dollars yeah yeah II seen
his stuff he did one about showing a
comparison between Team Fortress in 2017
and og team orphans just graphically and
it's really weird they actually like
downgraded a lot of visual elements from
the PC version yeah like I guess like
the gun on the medic like it would
rotate graphical touches that is the
case I would love to were they trying to
optimize the game when it went
free-to-play so it could run on like you
know yeah for less hardware you know for
more casual players like oh that was
just an interesting interesting thing
yeah I mean right yeah it's like for
just to communication between the little
back stories that come out between
certain characters same with overwatch I
love that multiplayer storytelling that
takes place
I remember Team Fortress 2 is
worried about [ __ ] I forgot about that
inspire so this is when they start
introducing all the Unitologist stuff
right yeah well right here this audio
logs a rich happing getting drinks for
my is this one the captain gets murdered
or maybe it's a little bit later
it could change I find out soon okay not
here but yeah you find out like the
captain got like stabbed yeah he was
like Unitologist or something well part
of the ship are you on right now I'm in
the medical Bay
okay Oh hence the globin organ busts
yeah they just put those there
weird decoration oh I can't pick it up
so I mentioned half-life I'll probably
like our playthrough have liked you
again recently yeah when we're doing
like an episode of a show on Metro last
light and half-life 2 how they were
inspired by half-life 2 metros good yeah
Exodus next year some point hopefully
yeah unless it gets delayed [ __ ] they
looked gorgeous on the Xbox one IX at e3
oh yeah yeah was that like running in
real time I think they said it was or
wasn't we know I wasn't running in real
time but that was like a it's using the
Xbox 1x yeah like I was a it's a
pre-recorded video that was but
apparently it was actually captured yeah
what they claimed yeah I wasn't a live
demo which I think they're a little bit
disingenuous about maybe or maybe that
maybe people just assume that but they
never said it I think people were like
calling him out on it but they were like
no that was actually like that was
captured yeah like that was us but
someone played that with a controller
yeah it was gameplay just wasn't alive
right yeah I don't think they ever said
it was live
yeah like a remade they could do they
could do some good stuff with lighting I
feel like and uh if they did like a
remake of this game
we're like a you know HD remaster about
the state lighting this game isn't good
I just think it the ten years since
they've came to come up with some pretty
good like new lighting tricks yep I
could just make this looking for metric
stuff yeah oh yeah like that
I like the fans and stuff that like you
know oh this baby's attacking the
pending bill glass sorry
oh yeah just beat wait oh no nevermind
it shoots him blows his head off that's
like a it's a fetus but it's got a human
head or it's got like a adult skull
super gross it but also kind of
attractive what a weird room yeah like
one of the why I'm thinking ignoring the
the gross monsters why do you have a
room with the babies flown in them
you're just that's just like you might
as well just leave bullets scattered
around for someone like what's the point
of this room you got a little hot water
for the the children thing into didn't
they like there's a little controversy
around that the Contras fact that it was
like you can use it whatever yeah yeah
you're straight up shooting reanimated
dead babies yeah yes we're doing this
when they're in there like play
environment
I love rotating and just yeah like a
minigame in itself Oh King plunger on
YouTube said I remember playing this
game when I was 12 I visited a school
friend to play this in the middle of the
night while he was sleeping good times I
hope he knew you were there I just snuck
into my friend's room and played this
and then went home before he ever he
woke up a man got to get them game
somehow what are you doing in my house
and just chloroform and to finish the
game Shh next day at school he's like
man I got really weird dreams you like
broke into my house and you only say
playing dead space really guys we're
gonna chef know what's good space I
definitely don't know anything about
Isaac Clark and mythology that was all
like 360 you'd have like one of those
like like 360 memory cards like that way
the safe is not there he doesn't suspect
what's a USB stick you have it says dead
space save on I don't know I name my
drives
not more button area you do that later
on with those fan blades right yes on
down so you don't get chopped is your
job things were cool at the time but I
wonder if they're cumbersome going back
the stuffing to is three has like that
to the Jets that you can maneuver with
right yes is just pretty much Magnum
boots and you have to pick a place and
dice like to shoot at it yeah it's like
early retching Clank oh geez Magnum
boots stuff yeah they took that in a
cool direction three where you're like
going from ship to ship and that's not
that's cool right yeah you're going
between the frigates and like the Med
ship and little cargo things that was
fun yeah it was rather than one ship I
was like a cluster well you're also
planetside to begin with and you go back
I believe wait around right volantis is
that there's at the planet that just
popped into my head for some reason I
have no idea
now once you land on the planet that's
pretty much fun okay
I think it's volantis no where did I see
the name volantis the name volantis
sounds familiar
I don't think that is oh yeah black is
that Star Wars right Game of Thrones
haha cool that I've been watching Game
of Thrones both wrong then is that where
the great the gray men are oh no that's
one of the first cities Daenerys goes to
a little braids okay never mind
it starts the feed this one dead space 3
planet what's called tau volantis I'm
scared okay so what is volantis okay
goddamn but I wonder what that meat and
we're depressing lad
something like two separate thing very
different franchises
yeah it must mean something last man
like worm yeah or something because
isn't it supposed to be like the the
like originator of Latin for origin of
male is wait the flying fish
oh so it's a constellation oh never mind
sorry it's oh no the words live ah dang
it it's the present participle that I do
not get those significance yes Chris
Chris Hawk on YouTube we did a whole
he asked what do you guys think about
Luke racing game we did a whole Lobby
chat on our livestream today yeah yeah
turns out battlefront to EA it did dice
did supposedly patch a lot based on
complaints but like who said kind of a
cynical way maybe they were just seeing
how much they could get away with of the
beta largely stem from a lot of well you
know like games were still only $60 and
this is the way we supplement true to
some extent yeah
but then when you find out like I've
ever seen a super bunny hop dude like
I'm videoing this
like tax havens to like avoid paying my
tax dollars yeah thanks to skeptical
words like okay you're doing these micro
transactions that make you tons of money
but it doesn't seem like that's actually
going
that's not pouring back into game
development is yeah pouring back into
paying your employees better it's going
into these like tax shelters and that's
where that's the part where I'm just
like oh like it's just as very apparent
corporate greed from the outside you
know yeah the the common refrain I feel
like that a lot of publishers say it's
like well it's games are different now
they're platforms that you can update
and whatnot and you have free to play
games like yeah those are free to play
and then you buy national want trying to
have their cake and eat it too right
people to overwatch strike me as games
to do loot crate's well because it's
their more aesthetic stuff titanfall 2
same thing you're just you can buy like
real web stuff but it's not for
something at all I need that now the
pulse rifle the pulse rifles they got
that like triangle reticle triangular
reticles rounds
well I love how you read a lot it like a
look revolver almost you'd like flip it
forward the new magazine in yeah Adam
miss Cal was just saying the planet
that's because he was tavel antis as
weird it must it must mean something
it's also weird that dead space
triggered that memory as opposed to Game
of Thrones which I literally watched
last night I bet I've been really
watching it the whole show oh really
yeah I'm on like the penultimate episode
beyond the wall or the one after that
hmm
so everyone outbreak oh yeah I never
played that when the server's were alive
but I have it still on my shelf at home
like a king plunger saying a new dead
space that'd be more open space station
yeah like I wanted to take that space
but actually like make it like a like an
actual open open kind of world would be
pretty cool yeah yeah it like this
almost but instead of traveling between
with the trams and just backtracking
more a little more freeform in its
exploration yeah would be really really
doing things in different order like
trendy GameSpot asked if I've ever seen
Game of Thrones he hasn't heard me
mention it no I have not what is that
here it's alright my brother was playing
this game for the first time and there
was a bug there where that the platform
you just moved went too far and then for
some reason no matter what he did he
could not pull it back it was stuff oh
no yeah so he had to restart something
because even me I think he reloaded the
save and it was still kept doing it it
was bad and you know that's he's
watching me play this and really wanted
to play it one of my brothers and got
pretty pissed off I recommended just
doing my brothers he's like he's like
loves like resident evil like foreign
stuff was like dude you should play dead
space I know if he has yet yeah
definitely should
I would even do coop 3 with him again
just for you know try it out yeah I've
done it I've played that game twice once
singer player once co-op with a friend
but yeah seem here I'd be curious to try
it again
Adam Surma it was just saying do you
reckon we'll see another dead space i
were talking about that earlier because
of EI they have like how many star wars
between battlefront to then they have an
egg's thing at a visceral respawn is
working on something titanfall devs I
have a hard time believing we'll see
dead space anytime soon they have said
they're not averse to bringing it back
but it's not I'm sure it's not there
their priority right now I wouldn't be
shocked to see another one but I would
be surprised at least in the next like
five years or so like if they I feel
like if they were gonna it would be it I
don't think they do dead space for I
think they would reboot it yeah but then
you look at something like Metroid Prime
and they're doing Metroid Prime for not
they're very different game very
different developer company but I think
they assumed they would do another prime
trilogy rather than continue yeah I
think they also just need to keep their
expectations in check I mean like the
other thing was like three they were
like oh it's got to sell like 5 million
copies or something yeah which is a lot
that is a very significant amount yeah
and asking that from a horror franchise
is practically impossible right yeah
that is that it's very high expectation
so I think they just need to kind of
keep their expectations in check much of
the game accordingly you know do do con
take a page out of the way hell-blade
sort of like a double-a sized game Wow
like I think it can have a smaller
budget you think of the way dead space
operates you know the use of white
shadows in claustrophobic spaces I think
you can really make something like that
work right I mean I think you think of
all the different like new IPs that
people that publishers would take risks
on if they knew that they were doing
like a like a midsize game that you
could beat in like eight to ten hours
and pay $30 for and would enough to
invest so much in it because it wouldn't
cost as much but
death of the outsider was DLC but it was
still standalone that was that's I'm
actually I played that yesterday I'm
about to finish it finally oh nice
I'm on the fifth mission now same with
Uncharted The Lost Legacy that's
standalone like the fact that it's you
know DLC kind of Chris Hawke was saying
are you scared of what microtransactions
can look like oh no future I have to
believe that at some point publishers
will start realizing that it's not even
worth it
well no that's the thing I thought they
would just say like oh it's bad press I
wonder if it's even worth it doing
anymore but then we looked at those
numbers from even just like ultimate
team EA they make 650 650 million a year
just from that mode across three sports
games I'm saying like they make so much
money off that stuff it's hard it's I
always underestimate it I'm like no
that's bad press they'll stop doing this
but they make there's those whales that
pay like $1,000 a year for that side and
you know what I would be a little okay
with that if they were then saying and
we're gonna take this money and we're
gonna pour it into some hashing projects
like yeah right like that would be then
I could say you know what that's
actually really cool rather than
maintaining the status quo and doing the
same thing with 819 right like that's
the part where it's like you're making
all this extra money and there's so
risk-averse right
oh man there's some GameInformer
shoutouts happening the twitch chat
Lionel horse package 9 mentioned Ben
Hansen and Dan Takei never actually
worked with the entak it came from her
but I had no Ben Hansen he's a goof but
he's very very good what he does someone
was asking what other game is what we'd
like to see updated in the spirit of
Halloween Friday 13th the obvious one
which got the update today I don't know
Friday the 13th it's kind of unique in
that it's they I mean obviously they
released it with the intention of
updating it constantly right under how
far they're gonna go with that what
other horror games would there be
we're doing our extra life charity
we haven't nailed down I think we kind
of nail down date but I don't think
we've announced it yet it's gonna be in
November we believe later November r7e
it's a 24 hour livestream but we do 72
hours in Australia UK offices yeah so
then we were talking about I kind of I
loved until dawn that like b-movie game
that uh who did that what's studio oh
because that was kind of a surprise yeah
that came out of nowhere that was a
surprise hit for sure they did that DLC
but it was a gonna on Rails shooter
super weird
oh the VR game okay that makes more
sense
I was confusing supergiant super die up
higher I keep forgetting that came out
this year to those I have not played
pyre it's really good and I should
because I'm a huge fan of those guys can
you do you know how many games you've
beaten this year like completely maybe
okay so like I've when I say beam I mean
like pretty much beaten like shadow for
I feel like you could play like thirty
five hours and maybe you didn't beat it
but you stride destiny to obviously you
don't really beat it destiny to I would
say I I did the raid so I feel like I
could say I have to say that you have to
do the raid but I feel like I'd beaten
it prey I beat prey that was one that
that's hard not to be its except for the
last like that was getting that I
couldn't put down
marathoned it's just so many I'd beat a
beat horizon zero dawn I do not I went
back and beated I after Chris oh no five
I actually have so that was the one I
was like I'm going to beat this I'm
going to do that yeah very close I think
for me it's prey persona 5 res equals 7
and you beat resident 7 I believe I did
B resonable 7 in VR I did one
playthrough of Nier automata which I
realize is not really the parents and
all near yet so I played this I think
this is the biggest disparity of my life
in a year between how many games I play
and how many have beaten because I've
probably played at this point a year I
would not be surprised if I played like
65 games new games including like indie
hits and stuff hell-blade I beat I think
they might have been asking us what
we're playing on its controller oh yeah
that is a playing on PC yeah all right
some lives playing on PC be just an Xbox
and some we're just asking if we marry
kitchen are gonna be playing Resident
7vr
so yeah we yeah was now we've beaten
resonable well we've beaten the two
campaigns whereas Evil six we're saving
Jake Wesker and sherry Birkins for like
a bonus episode at some point that's
maybe my favorite yeah I know we just we
made sure to do Leon and Christmas was
like there's the series characters yeah
patrol sherry is two for me is that
wouldn't maybe the cheesiest yeah and I
kind of like the other cert so oh no
[ __ ] that might actually be a good time
to end it anyway but the other ones are
so melodramatic in a way that's like
especially that Chris one oh my god it
is really bad holding with Pierre I'm
just like it was fun though Farseer he's
just playing co-op oh yeah yeah we I
don't think we're gonna do resin evil 7
in VR I want her to try it at some point
Jenna look I know you have you played
through the whole thing of your way
through the whole thing in via and I
want to do that he was
really cool that's like one of the I
would say Prime VR experience right now
especially on PlayStation probably it's
not the best yeah
like that and what do you want to call
it thumper probably right good but um
and super hot it's also really good is
that that's not on PSP our I don't think
yeah but that's very good PR but I don't
think we're to do anything we're gonna
have Mary sitting right here we found
Luke is playing on the screen because
she's somehow avoided like spoilers of
any kind for resonable 7
great and there you want to go on there
is wide as possible maybe not a story
twist but there's definitely a twist
that she would not know there's like a
thing that a big part that happened that
she doesn't know about if she just based
on trailers cuz they didn't show it
which was great
that part was cool and scary and VR cool
oh yeah yeah I want to try that soon I
mean I've tried I want to play the hole
yeah just don't house difficulty it's
it's so weird like it kind of almost
feels weird playing that game not in VR
like just yeah like the experiencing
those environments it's like looking at
a photograph of like those environments
okay most like being there such a good
sense of space I though when we did that
like scare compilation video we played
through the Attic seen in the which is a
good scene is the cabin boathouse
whatever they call it behind the mansion
and you hear the piano play really quick
like doodoo and then you go in there's
no playing and yeah but going into the
Attic when you're in VR you're you're
not just like until like writing a
character into the Attic you yourself
are going up there and it's really
really messed up it's fun though it's
good and you aim with your head right
you yep look and that feels really good
me actually feels really good yeah feels
we were going back to an analogue after
that all right god that game is really
good that's that's my top 5 of the year
so Santa's as well what I think the
biggest hiccup in that is the first boss
fight for me after everything after that
I love ya most most everything after
that I love but that first boss fight
you can go wrong too scripted for me the
rest of the have you have you tried the
madhouse difficulty no it's it changes
that like the enemy placement and
arranged mode yeah and the old-school
residence but even more so range mode
being like yeah you have to the save box
inventory is not shared across all save
box it's actually each say box has what
you put something into that say box
that's the box you have to go back to
yeah to get it yeah so like the game is
just like functionally like yeah gun
placements all this stuff around it and
it makes it it makes that game feel
fresh first I can play through so highly
recommend that if you haven't tried that
out in it stuff like like in when you
play the first one you could kind of
cheese like when Jack's chasing you
we're like okay he won't chase me in the
he won't chase me in the yeah in the
laundry room he won't show up in there
he won't show up in the hallway for the
most part right yeah he totally does
kill oh okay yeah he goes in to save
room stuff too he went into the UH he
went into the on the hallway he was like
chasing me he's way more persistent he
shows up way earlier like there's that
you know there's that part where you go
like you think he's gone and then like
he there's that review on the bathroom
right yeah he'll show up like almost
immediately before the bathroom and
you're like oh he's right here shoot
like do you know what you're talking
about and what people in the chat are
saying like Marguerite just I mean if
you're not in the gym yet if you're in
the twitch and not easy I don't want to
spoil it but like well no that's not I
mean you don't know what's happened
Marguerite busting through the window
I'm like wait I can't wait for Mary to
because like six and five have not been
scary for isn't even that scary like no
seven gets you it's I can't dude I
remember that part in VR though her
busting through the window and VR oh my
god and my girlfriend was just watching
me the whole time and laughing her ass
out yeah someone just asking is the lack
of new IPs a concern right now I'd
actually say this year was pretty
I mean horizon was new I mean days gone
is coming out but that looks just like a
zombie game now I would say that I'm not
about a lack of new IPs I think I'm
more specifically companies like EA or I
feel like are dropping the ball but I
think there's plenty of other people
picking up the slack so on that I'm not
too worried about it yeah for sure it's
a lot to be optimistic about this year
this I the longer we go this year and we
haven't even gotten like three huge four
huge games six huge games sorry but Call
of Duty obviously is in the new
battlefront I knew but aside from that
like xeno gear
Xenoblade sorry nods you know gear very
different
Xenoblade Mario Odyssey Assassin's Creed
Wolfenstein - there's this probably the
best year ever this like rivals like 98
was it 98 2011 North good yeah great
year
again you oxygen apologies if I'm
butchering him YouTube chat I just twist
that TV slash GameSpot and that'll be uh
yep that's the link we are coming up on
the end but over for future reference
that is the so just files I love it he's
he's not he's not trained he just
probably it's not that effective yeah
but it's I always loved in um two if you
if you stop long enough you just start
swearing just like [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
think you have to do it like a couple
times just kidding exhausted and pissed
off yeah he's getting like really angry
that's good don't touch it like that
just even right from the beginning when
Jack is just slowly chasing you I can't
wait to see Mary deal with that for the
record we're talking my resident can
evil its myself in Marrakech who used to
be a GameSpot she's at twitch now we've
been playing through every numbered
resonable game we as of now we have
beaten six but we will not have the
finale up until a week from tomorrow
which will be the 21st of October she's
going Australia for she's going down to
LA for twitch down a long beach for
twitchcon for like a week --is-- and
then she's going Australia for a pax
Australia for two weeks so we're
debating on maybe taking a week off so
she can come back and just play through
seven rather because that game is not
like six it's not there are kind of
chapters but it's all but barely because
it's all one big space right volved it's
mainly like Metroidvania is kind of
backtracking like the first game more
like the uh other resin evils you did
where it's just like we got to a safe
room awesome yeah and I don't want her
to start it and lose track of what she
was doing cuz you kind of do have to
like know where you're at in that game
for the most part I could refresh her
but kind of want to just play through
the whole thing and I don't think we
have time this weekend to play through
like half of it
so I don't know we'll see but no we
won't be playing it in VR to go back to
question that Adam asked
get that line gun in the rifle yeah Oh
Chris Hawk brings a bit interesting what
do you think Resident Evil 2 remastered
will falter oh yeah yeah I mean they
haven't mentioned anything about it I
still hope that's happening um I am very
very optimistic that it's still
happening
okay I'll say that cool cool I don't I
can't speak to the potential quality of
if rise able to remake will be good but
I I'm very very very positive about it
hopefully still happening sure I mean
the well like it wasn't like remake like
their fastest selling like digital
download for one you mean or the actual
no no like when they did like the remake
of the read the remastering of the
remake of Resident Evil 1 right on ps4
Xbox one right
and yeah ps4 Xbox one and steam yeah and
it sold like really really well so like
a million like a day or two and they're
the origins collection with that and
zero so this is interesting because 0
when they made that sorry res Evil
remake was the team that made 0 if I'm
not mistaken or so this I'm screwed to
suck Razzie will to remake the team that
was said to be working on it and
hopefully still working on it has not
wasn't most of them were not on a
traditional resonable game before so
this is their first time tackling
something like that yeah just by the
fact that to remake all the other things
that most of this team worked on were
like the third-person action over the
shoulder games so that is the one worry
I have but I'm still very optimistic
yeah and I may be unfairly so have a
pretty high standards for it because
well the series set high standards sure
but so I I loved I even like the first
the PlayStation 1 version of Resident
Evil I think it's still a really good
game yeah and I think remake is like
remakes one of my favorite games of all
time right right so love that game I do
think that the original 2 though is
better than 1 or then yeah yeah it's
remake 2 one for me exactly so
by that logic the my expectations for
the quality of a remake of - yeah like
so high which is again probably very
unfair but like that's just kind of how
it is logically yeah logically the
remake of - should be the greatest thing
ever the most faithful remake up - or
maybe not even just faithful but the
best remake up supers remake was super
different than resonable one but they
knew what they should change what they
shouldn't what they should opt it's such
a perfect example of yeah yeah like it's
like I have very high expectations of
that remake and that's probably been my
psychiatrist know I don't know I'm
optimistic about it we'll see you wanna
go to next safe station or just close
out or I don't know if you plan on
making this backup at so I don't have
time for this let's see we're gonna grab
a let's do this right here got your line
gun oh these things yeah yeah so these
are these add a new layer because when
you see them in a room with other
enemies you want to point them before
they those are the things that actually
convert people right and one of those
species that convert
you want to get him he's gonna start
Chris Hawk I don't marry and I first are
focused on once we beat seven to go back
to let's turn we're gonna focus on rest
Code Veronica and resonable zero like
the president to everyone it's so gross
all right that's a good a time as any
and there's your femur there's your ribs
all right all right let's uh close out
any last thoughts how does it feel going
back to dead space is still a real good
game if you've never played dead space
one I bet you it's like really cheap on
Steam probably right it must be must be
sale a few months ago yeah go pick us up
here and played it definitely have an
excuse among all the other games coming
out then don't play this go play
Resident Evil games just complain
Chet Oh any evil within two is out as a
playable within two ps4 Xone PC yeah
there's no shortage of games to play we
will be back as always monday 11:00 a.m.
Pacific I don't know what we're
streaming yet do you know you know hey
we'll be back imma still be back we will
be back next week with a lot of yard
like I said even within to review is up
jean-luc cut the video review Alessandra
wrote it so that's up on YouTube
GameSpot you can go read the full review
eight out of 10 on GameSpot very
positive game especially considering the
last one kind of faltered it's later
hours so this one seems like tango
gameworks kind of made good on the
potential of the first game Shinji
Mikami no sir
cool but as always thank you for joining
in twitch YouTube also today is the
final day I believe it's still running
we've been doing a giveaway all week for
the evil within - oh yeah if you go to
GameSpot there should be a link or if
you follow us on Twitter Shiva I think
every day has been she runs her Twitter
account she's been tweeting out the
giveaway code she'll you essentially get
to pick ps4 Xbox one evil then - but
today is the grand prize day so two
random people will be picked I wish I
had the JPEG right now but we don't you
can go check it out on the site but evil
within two skinned at ps4 Pro and Xbox
one s it's really good looking consoles
next week
also giving away dishonored themed
consoles because it's dishonoured fifth
anniversary last week and XCOM enemy
Unknown so there's like a bunch of
antifreeze rights maybe one of the first
giveaways we've had where I'm actually
jealous that I can't have those yes it's
really good cool well so yeah today go
check out our link on the games on
GameSpot for the giveaway again I think
it's still running it should be done by
the end of today so this is kind of your
last chance to go check it out
you might win one of those two consoles
if you don't already have them or if you
just want to hold into themed console
you can get them but anyway thank you
for joining John Luke thanks for playing
yeah walk us through it
I just want to play this now but there
it is oops you riot thank you if you're
in the twitch chat GameSpot evil within
two ps4 Xbox one and PC giveaway and
then those two consoles check that out
thanks you and we'll see everyone around
thanks for joining thanks